سجال سياسي حاد هجمات متبادله حرب
جيوسياسيه مناورات عسكريه وازمه غذاء هذه
هي العناوين يتصدرها البحر الاسود الذي
يسوده توتر متزايد بين روسيا من جهه
واوكرانيا وحلفائها من جهه اخرى وذلك منذ
انتهاء العمل باتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاساسي لامدادات الاغذيه في العالم البحر
الاسود هو بحر داخلي بين الجزء الجنوبي
الشرقي من اوروبا
واسيا الصغرى ويتصل بالبحر الابيض المتوسط
عن طريق مضيق البوسفور وبحري مرمره
تصب فيه انهار كثيره يطلق عليه البحر
الاسود ليس بسبب سواد لون مياهه بل لكثره
الغيوم فوقه يعتبر احد ابرز المنافذ
البحريه الروسيه نحو المياه الدافئه وتحيط
به دول روسيا واوكرانيا
بلغاريا
وتركيا وجورجيا كما تشاهدون البحر الاسود
نادرا ما يعد من بين اهم المساحات
الاستراتيجيه في العالم حتى بين المسطحات
المائيه لقد حظي بحر جنوب الصين والخليج
العربي وشرق البحر الابيض المتوسط بالمزيد
من الاهتمام في السنوات الاخيره
طبعا هذا على الرغم من وقوع عشر حروب
مذهله على ساحره او بالقرب من من شاطئهم
منذ نهايه الحرب البارده اكثر من اي مساحه
بحريه اخرى في العالم
حموله تجاريه ضخمه تمر عبر البحر الاسود
سجل طريق بحر الشمال الروسي الذي نال
الكثير من الاهتمام سجل رقما قياسيا في
الحموله بلغ نحو 35 مليون طن من البضائع
وذلك عام 2021
البحر الاسود هو المكان الذي تلتقي فيه
العديد من كبرى القوى في العالم روسيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي وتركيا وحلف شمال
الاطلسيه الذي يجلب معه الوراه المتحده مع
العلم انه لا تتمتع اي من هذه القوه
بالهيمنه على هذا البحر
في الساعات الماضيه اعلنت موسكو ان القوات
الروسيه اجرت تدريبات عسكريه اطلقت خلالها
صواريخ في البحر الاسود
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان سفن تابعه
لاصول البحر الاسود الروسي اطلقت صواريخ
كروز مضاده للسفن على زورق حدد هدفا في
منطقه التدريب القتالي في الجزء الشمالي
الغربي من البحر الاسود